why is Coppa 19 hitting some communities
harder than others and who exactly has
been hit hardest we're seeing this
happen across the country but to better
understand the divide we zeroed in on
two New York City boroughs the Bronx and
Manhattan even though Manhattan has more
people the Bronx has more cases and more
deaths we wanted to understand the
reasons for this gap so we compared the
borough's based on 3criteria why more
people are getting infected being
hospitalized and dying from kovin 19:00
and it's revealed this pandemic is
attacking two very different Americas
let's look at why there's a difference
in infection numbers between the two
boroughs we'll start with income the
Bronx is the poorest borough in the city
with a median income of $38,000 compared
to Manhattan's $82,000 almost 60% of
people in the Bronx are paying more than
they can afford for housing which has
led to more multi-generational housing
in the Bronx and more residents in
public housing than any other borough
for every apartment in the Bronx there
are two point eight people living in it
compare that to the two people living in
every apartment in Manhattan more people
at home likely means more people get
sick overall there's 350,000 more
housing units in Manhattan than the
Bronx and better quality housing see
this map most residents in the Bronx are
dealing with maintenance problems like
leaks rats cracks plumbing and broken
toilets these issues alone make it more
challenging to live at home not to
mention having to work from home because
of Cova 19 that is if you can work from
home according to the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics of those Americans making
less than $33,000 a year which are these
neighborhoods in the Bronx 9% of people
could work from home whereas of those
people making more than 79 thousand
dollars a year all of these
neighborhoods in Manhattan
60% could work from home
on the other hand in the Bronx residents
who can't work from home are most likely
out of a job and tight on money or
they're essential workers think grocery
store clerks transit employees
trash collectors health care workers
many of those people you see daily out
on the front lines 17% of frontline
workers in New York City are coming from
the Bronx while just 12% are from
Manhattan and for the majority of these
essential workers getting to their job
means taking the subway subway ridership
has dropped across the city but not by
the same amount in Manhattan 75% fewer
people are riding but in the Bronx
ridership has dropped only 55% so trains
to and from the Bronx can be packed
especially with reduced subway services
plus people from the Bronx face longer
commutes than people in Manhattan on
average 12 point 7 minutes longer of
standing body-to-body with that person
who's maybe coughing okay let's move on
to the second criterion let's say
someone in each borough does get the
virus
what will influence whether they become
hospitalized the Bronx has had over
10,000 hospitalizations Manhattan about
6,000 every year New York counties are
ranked based on their health last year
Manhattan was 6 best in the state the
Bronx dead last out of 62 counties this
is based on things like access to
clinical care the environment and
pre-existing conditions the Bronx has
higher rates of pre-existing conditions
like asthma heart disease and obesity
conditions that increase the risk of a
severe Cova 19 case to explain why this
is we're gonna have to go deep
we'll start with obesity rates between
the two boroughs studies have shown that
poor diets and lack of exercise are
linked to obesity and in the Bronx
families facing money problems are
limited time are forced to turn to
cheaper or prepackaged foods 87% of kids
in the Bronx rely on free or reduced
school lunches which are packed with
salt and fat
plus the Bronx has almost doubled the
amount of food stamps per individual
compared to Manhattan but the greatest
contributor to diet though is access and
the Bronx has historically had some of
the worst food deserts in the country
where it's hard to find affordable and
healthy food close to home all of these
factors have created a lack of healthy
resources for generations in the Bronx
they lead to unhealthy eating habits and
high rates of obesity and diabetes
both pre-existing conditions that
increase your risk of death from covin
19 on the other hand in Manhattan life
expectancy and access to healthy food is
much higher people not only have more
access to grocery stores they also have
more gyms to choose from simply put
these things and disposable income make
it a lot easier to be healthier here
another pre-existing condition that
skyrockets risk of Cova nineteen
hospitalization asthma in big cities
studies have shown pollution is a major
cause of asthma pollution is bad across
New York City but the Bronx has the
highest rates of asthma related
emergency room visits there's even a
place nicknamed asthma alley in the
South Bronx it's surrounded by four
highways and sanitation and sewage
facilities there's also a bunch of
trucks coming and going from all of
these distribution centers these food
wholesalers and the Fresh Direct
distribution center here and the Wall
Street Journal and New York Post
printing press here at last count asthma
hospitalizations were 27 times higher in
this area than the rest of the city bad
asthma equals a higher risk of being
hospitalized with Kovan 19 and needing a
ventilator to help you breathe but it
gets worse when you take into account
how accessible medical professionals are
in these areas in Manhattan there's one
physician for every 750 people in the
Bronx there's one physician for every
one thousand 770 people there are also
fewer hospital beds in the Bronx
Manhattan has almost doubled the amount
of hospitals for only a 15% larger
population that brings us to our third
and final criterion why are more people
dying due to Cova 19 in the Bronx in
Manhattan for emergency hospitals were
constructed to combat coronavirus while
the Bronx was promised one the borough
hasn't gotten it yet quality care also
isn't as accessible in the Bronx on
average Manhattan hospitals received 3
out of 5 stars
Bronx hospitals received 1.2 out of 5
stars
Jacobi hospital in the Bronx is one of
the five worst rated hospitals in the
nation add in the effect of pre-existing
conditions we talked about earlier and
the Bronx has had 2800 deaths of people
with underlying conditions Manhattan
almost 1,300 altogether as of May 10th
Manhattan's death toll was 1946 while
the Bronx hit 3177 deaths and when you
break down New York City's death toll
people of color are two times more
likely to die of coronavirus in the
Bronx the population is 85% black or
Hispanic
whereas in Manhattan 64 percent of the
population is white this is why you're
seeing headlines that a disproportionate
number of people of color are dying of
kovat 19
but these deaths go beyond coronavirus
for the bronx cycles of income
inequality food deserts poor health care
fewer hospitals and crumbling housing
have harmed communities of color for
generations and we see this pattern
repeat itself again and again with black
and brown communities across the country
Baltimore Detroit Chicago st. Louis Los
Angeles this disease is not the great
equalizer yes anyone can get covin 19
but not everyone is as vulnerable to
dying from it that has everything to do
with the problems in place long before
this ever started
[Music]